let's begin a bit of a discussion on
this okay ask the learner what we're
doing is we're exploring we just kind of
sandy out and seeing what happens okay
yeah what the first questions we raised
was please do share
these two here do these constitutes
different ages well I'm going to pose
the question to you do you know you're
dirt they and how do you know whether
they do or don't they want to suggest a
little later applying an D or that
doesn't really matter
aha so this I can remove all about you 7
which is that addition of multiplication
are do they don't remember the name on
that such a receipt where you change
order to do whatever you like
it's not a common word which is ironic
because then what the word is we say
operations are commutative if you can do
them in any order and you can change
things around don't change the order
okay
as the limit we've been thinking about
addition and then we're going to think
surely that multiplication neither of
which affect the order okay and
ultimately the final question is now
what is the final question sail against
the Ottoman won't lose the questions the
question location what's the questions
being honest what what are their ages
right to reach I would reply I think
these two give us the same information
okay so I'm just going to take off this
one okay now I've also put you to slight
disadvantage which I I can't ask you to
come up randomly and then you sort of
written formula are my they're mine are
not there so I can't put them down or
whatever these are in somewhat random
order okay
I wonder if anyone has an order to the
way that they've written it down because
that will help us to make sure we get
all the far what if you close your water
how did you laid out start with the age
of 1 1 to 10 yeah in one brain or in
than 1 for 8 and 1 5 7 and 1 for 6
okay so if you lock in the age of one
child then it becomes quite easy to work
out whether other to have to be a
certain limited number of ages right
why are we doing this you want to
explore in a logical fashion like if you
have
is to explore if you explore in a
logical fashion with a pattern to it
when you make sure that you don't miss
anything right whereas if you go about
it in somewhat random order it's like la
tonight can I get that spot I don't know
it's hard to keep track
okay so yes this is a way that you
explore well pause for me I've written
down or different down on the edges of
the three children has possibilities but
all I've really thought about is the
first piece of information okay now I'm
going to think about the second which
requires me to do one I'm going to help
them multiply across right now just a
little minor note which is not important
er points I'm going to do it anyway in
if it didn't really have 22 close so we
kind of run out really quickly at
letters which I've described these
that's why we is Greek letters so often
it also cause creaking in central attics
some of you will see this symbol there
one don't drink better than is its Sigma
right so because it's the I Greek
equivalent of the letter S for us you
will often see that when you want to
describe the sum of a set of numbers
okay so when you see Sigma you should
read that its own
I actually we're boring all of these
have the same Sigma or 13 okay I want a
product so therefore instead of this
which everyone knows and recognizes a
mathematical symbol
I've actually going to use does look
very different but hopefully we sit
together
distinguished enough I'm going to use a
capital PI because Greek letters have
capitals and lowercase just like we do
if Sigma says the sum what do you think
PI thirds or take applied yes have a
look at the clues it's a product okay so
I'm going to work out all over products
over here can you help me out with the
first one fine 20 this is yeah I can
that's why I live that's the reason
35 lucky seven it was fun many miss this
we already have the don't worry right
because we already decided be the sets
at one of them so I'm going to just
slice of nothing we're exploring it's
all good but we're actually the same
time you might notice we're eliminating
option okay we're we got here what this
or two times two times three fifty sixty
and seventy six okay okay now I'm going
to ask you to go back because I know for
a fact and you can know for a fact as
well that we haven't got them all how do
we know we haven't got them all
any suggestions yeah what do you think
we have any island every single
personally so every single number okay
number one it's like well we just
haven't done the ball like what this is
a pretty short list okay but actually
even the question tells you something a
bit quicker than that there's something
in question that tells us I don't have
the full list yet do that but they both
worked out there's a three ages multiply
and they pointed to the door and they're
like ice that number right now when you
when they both looked at that number
they both looked and what was the the
person to whatever the other person was
what was it response when they don't
look at the number I need to know more I
need to know more they'll have a look at
the information you've got here if this
was the complete set then I don't need
to know any more if we're both looking
the door and we can see twenty on the
door or we can see four two on the door
do you see why in this situation I
totally any more information why
okay ah okay now the reason why I don't
I have all the information is because
every single in others is unique right
so if I saw 32 then I know this is the
age like up on the door right if I saw
48 that I know this is you right because
they're all different but the fact that
he suggests or [ __ ] whoever it is cuz I
don't know yet I need to know more means
there must be more ages so that repeats
what's here okay so we want you to go
back we're clearly not finished
exploring yet okay can you see if this
is a little bit up to you nine
possibilities there's a few more not
much more I should point out in fact
you've got more than half of them but
there's some missing can you try to work
dinner